[QUIZ But does it work? Which of the following will our optimizer do?]
We'll definitely replace A times 1 with A. We wrote the code for that.
And we'll definitely replace A times [0] with 0.
This next one--0 times A--looks super tempting
but if you switch back for just a moment,
you'll notice that our optimizer is not symmetric.
We're only checking for the B--the right position--
to be the constant number.
That means we will not perform this optimization.
Similarly, A times 1 times 1
is going to depend a bit on what the input abstract syntax tree is,
but at the end of the day, this will actually produce
something like A times 1.
We apply the rule once, but since we don't call ourselves recursively
we're not going to notice that 1 times 1 is 1,
and then also A times 1 is A.
Currently, our optimizer can only do 1 optimization.
Similarly, here we'd really like to reason
that 5 times 0 is 0
so A + 0 should be A,
but our optimizer only checks 1 thing at the top level
so it won't notice that yet.